bonjour vous venez sur les messieurs
militants aujourd'hui on n'y avait pas
le sien ça va me servir
avec alice là on va renforcer un petit
peu déficient
mais s'est gardée bien déficit dans une
vie
avec aso
t
alors voir mouvement est dit on le
support de poule roger
voilà donc le but du mouvement et
les gens de la rue
voilà le jour d'arrêt c'est bien pas le
regard vers le bas congo
et le talon avec le club dirigé
valenciennes tout le monde
je pense que le rapport
par ailleurs des faits
et un peu de sauce doit renforcer sur
lozon donc on va alterner gauche et
droit d'en prendre
doc seconde mort vous le faire par la
qualifiée corruption élastique merci à
vous d'avoir suivi notre édition minutes
forme et on s'est dit à très bientôt
pour de nouveaux mouvements les fessiers
fait 20 à 30 répétition 3 5 séries trois
fois par semaine pour ne pas forcer sur
le dos regardez le sol afin d'optimiser
votre mouvement ne posaient pas votre
pied à terre